- [Instructor] We're asked
what is the value of the point
graphed on the number line
and this is the point right
over here, so pause this video
and see if you can figure
that out before we figure it out together.
All right so let's try to
figure it out together now.
So let's see this point is
between this is going to be
this is the tenths place
this is the hundredths place
so this over here is three
hundredths and this over here
is four hundredths.
So our point is between three
hundredths and four hundredths
and the space between three
is divided into ten equal spaces.
So if this whole thing is
a hundredth, so this whole
thing is equal to 0.01 the
difference between that,
that's a hundredth so then
each tenth of that is going
to be a thousandth.
So let me, I don't want to
make this too messy so this
right over here will be
one tenth of a hundredth
which is going to be a thousandth,
so it's going to be 0.001
we have a one in the thousandths place.
So one way to think about it,
this number is going to be
0.03 so we have our three
hundredths but then let's see
how many thousandths we have
to add to it to get to this
value right over here.
We have to add one
thousandth, two thousandths,
three thousandths, four
thousandths, five thousandths,
six thousandths, seven
thousandths, and eight thousandths.
So we're starting at three
hundredths and then we are adding
eight thousandths so you add
0.008 to get to this value.
So if you were to add these
two together you're going
to have three hundredths
and then the next place over
is the thousandths place
and we have eight of them.
So this point right over
here is 0.038 or you could do
this as 38 thousandths
because three hundredths is 30
thousandths, so any way you
want to view it, this is
the value of the point graphed
on the number line 0.038.